alors vous vous demandez tout ce qui y
est ah oui le ou la nouvelle
chroniqueuse de tpm paix castaldi rage
et l'arabe est sorti de rentrer chez
vous mais je me dis mais après réflexion
et devant jenny a bondi prime à morgane
tard morgan kelly
je reste sur sonia rolland je pense
sonia rolland
il reste seulement rollin arielle
dombasle le corps est apte à ma première
balle le come back de l'âme bac de là
puisque chouette égalament ouais j'ai
parfois peur d'avoir à savoir enora
balle est déjà dans l'émission de
derrick
allez allez allez dans la famille les
chéris jeu de rappeler que les rivières
pourpres
c'est ce soir sur france 2 avec olivier
marchal merci olivier d'avoir excédé
venir à moi reçu de vous tous je vais
demander après le décompte et on va
rendre l'antenne direct puisqu'il y aura
la chance sourit derrière on reviendra
sur cette info demain vous pourrez lui
poser toutes les questions que vous
voudrez demain à ceux où cette nouvelle
chroniqueuse elle vous dira pourquoi on
a décidé de la faire entrer dans
l'équipe
vous allez bien sûr pouvoir lui poser
toutes les questions ou aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux demain vous demanderez
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
aussi vous la connaissez bien c'est une
femme elle est déjà venue dans
l'émission en chroniqueuse
il y avait une panthère la panthère est
le signe d'énergie la nouvelle
chroniqueuse et je vous dis tout de
suite d'ailleurs vous allez à découvrir
chez vous et je vous dis dès maintenant
on se retrouve demain dans touche pas à
mon poste avec miss france la nouvelle
miss france qui sera avec nous tout de
suite c'est l' agence tous risques
sur ces 8 vous allez voir son visage on
va rendre l'antenne directement après la
nouvelle chroniqueuse de tpm pays c'est
[Musique]
consommation
[Applaudissements]